well joining me now is host of podcast
um Cara swisher and Seth Dillon CEO of
the studio website Babylon B who met
Trump actually this week to discuss all
this uh and we've got my pack as well
the broadcaster Alex Phillips Lauren
commentator all around Adrian and talk
to the international editor Isabel
eggshell so a stellar panel of frenzied
social media uses on my ad have all been
gathered to debate all this uh let me
start with you Seth Dylan because you're
really one of the reasons that Elon Musk
ended up buying Twitter if you believe
his tweets because he was incense that
people like you were getting effectively
censored and banned by the former
Twitter regime and that this was only
ever skewed towards conservatives
well yeah I don't think that we were the
sole reason that he did that I think he
was primarily concerned about restoring
free speech and we were one egregious
example of how just making jokes you
know making jokes that you're not
supposed to make was resulting in
suspensions where our speech was being
curbed so
um you know he saw that as problematic
and wanted to step in and do something
about it and I I think it's a great
thing that he did somebody needed to as
Bill Maher said Twitter needs a new
sheriff they weren't doing a very good
job deciding what's true and what's
right and what's hateful yeah well I can
really agree and it always seemed to be
skewed one way towards people on the
right so Carl Swisher I mean that was my
experience as somebody who sits you know
pretty much in the middle a lot to
consider myself I I was watching this
thinking well it is only actually people
on the right who were getting slung off
Twitter it's only people like Babylon
but it's only people like Donald Trump
it's never the hardcore left who
sometimes can be just as outrageous and
defensive
well you know the Babylon bee thing was
ridiculous I would agree that they
shouldn't have been kicked off I mean
you can think it's the joke was funny or
not but it was there was nothing wrong
with having satire and things like that
on there and I think it gets more
problematic when you have someone like
Donald Trump possibly uh promoting
violence and that's the problem here is
that they have these rules and they were
they were just they were never they were
random and that's the problem with it I
don't necessarily think there's any
beard stroking Bernie Sanders person I
think that's a Trope also
um but that they were randomly
um put in place and there's actually
been some new reporting also that they
they were too scared to take things down
too of conservatives and I think that's
the problem is that these companies were
unaccountable to anyone as you noted
um have no ability to make rules that
they stick to and that's that's the
problem with Facebook too they sort of
did this two-year ban what's a two-year
ban what does that mean
um because they they didn't have the
guts to kick them off I guess or not or
I don't don't kick them off if you don't
think it's a real ban and so I think the
problem is these are make being made by
singular people uh even if it's Elon
Musk he had the same problem this week
with Nick Fuentes he brought him back on
and he kicked him right off
um
yeah Kanye West I think it's going to be
a problem forever because they make
these rules they don't enforce them and
then they change them and nothing makes
sense and that that to me is the real
problem is that you're putting people in
place that don't have any business
making decisions for the rest of society
and including real societal harm uh
possibly yes yeah I don't disagree with
that I mean Seth Dillon you were
actually with Donald Trump uh yesterday
I think um you were having dinner with
him what was his view about whether he
should come back onto social media
because obviously he's had the
invitation to come back to Twitter which
he hasn't taken yet because he has his
own truth social media platform but did
you get a feeling he is going to come
steaming back
I'm not sure I don't know that he's made
that decision yet
um but he shares the concerns a lot of
Americans can share that there's
politically motivated Viewpoint
discrimination happening on these
platforms he was a victim of it we've
been a victim of it you know it whether
it goes one way or not I don't think is
really the issue
um sure it's a problem if it's if it's
one-sided or the rules aren't being
applied fairly but this is the the
Public Square of the Modern Age where
people need to be able to have a voice
there's a recent case that just happened
you know you had this house bill 20 was
passed in Texas where they were trying
to make politically motivated Viewpoint
discrimination illegal and an Obama
appointed judge enjoined that law and
then the fifth Circuit Court of Appeals
looked at it they said no listen there
is no hidden right to censor in the
First Amendment censorship isn't speech
so these platforms don't have a
constitutional right to be able to
censor you they need to let you speak
and express your viewpoints they
shouldn't be deciding what's true they
shouldn't be moderating jokes because
they think the jokes are hateful and
saying things like when Trump got kicked
off Twitter people don't know this but
Trump got kicked off Twitter for saying
I won't be attending the inauguration
and he said my supporters will have a
voice long into the future what rule
does that supposedly violate it's not
unlawful speech it's not inciting anyone
it's not calling for anything you have
to read that into it and that's the
problem is you can you should be able to
express your opinions say what you
believe even if it's not true you have a
right to be wrong Hillary Clinton said
that his election in 2016 was
illegitimate she had every right to say
that if she wanted to say that I was
going to make that point is it it was
exactly the same thing about that they
all said that that election was stolen
from them there was no qualitative
differences
not accurate
you know look it was slightly different
but to me the generalized sort of
overview of it all it's not much
difference between one group of people
saying it's different directions let me
say one thing first of all you're saying
it's a Public Square it's not a Public
Square it's a profit-making business
they can do whatever they want you can
do whatever you want you don't have any
right to be on Twitter you don't have
any right to be on Facebook and I think
that's the problem is we've become to
think of it as that I think the real
problem is when the government does
intervene including in Texas which is
going to get a going to be an overruled
because of the First Amendment they
should also be able to put on what they
want and I think the problem is
everyone's decided they own these things
we did start the internet the U.S
taxpayer paid for the internet and
that's for sure but these businesses can
do whatever they want the real problem
it seems to me the most egregious
example I think of what was going on was
the New York Post exposed day of Hunter
Biden agree and that laptop several
weeks before that election uh where we
don't know what would have happened if
if Twitter hadn't banned the New York
Post site completely and basically
airbrushed that expose which turned out
right but that was let me just say that
was yeah but I changed it really quickly
they you and I have talked about this
they changed it really quickly they said
they made a mistake he said it in
Congress
Dominion I didn't change it until after
the election and the big unanswerable
question now is what impact would it
have had if the mainstream media had not
all convinced themselves this was
Russian propaganda and had actually gone
after that story as aggressively as they
should have done three weeks before an
election it could have tilted things
Trump's way so you actually had a direct
example of a social media platform
Banning a story and a newspaper from
publishing that true story which could
have influenced the result of an
election
and you have the same thing with Fox and
Dominion should they have been able to
broadcast those election things I mean I
think that's the problem is that these
sites have so much power over everyone
and yet they're private companies and so
what is the what is the solution in the
case of Babylon Bay it takes Elon Musk
to buy it and let them back on and
that's the solution unfortunately a
billionaire has to buy it
um I think the problem is is we've
gotten we have these private uh profit
making companies making decisions for
all of society and by the way they're
allowed to even if they make a mistake
even if they make the wrong call even if
they say we need to make a distinction
though we need to make a distinction
between how it is and how it should be
and like you just acknowledged these
private companies exercised a ton of
power the primary threat to speech used
to be the government but now because
people speak online the primary threat
to speech is these online forums that
are owned by private companies and the
question like justice Thomas is asking
is should SEC should a common carrier
Doctrine apply to them should we have
rules in place regulations in place
where uh discriminate nation is
prohibited I think a good argument can
be made the common carrier Doctrine
could and should apply to these private
companies even though they're privately
owned so that people are not
discriminated against unfairly and they
still have a voice let me ask you let me
ask you where do you think the line is
with freedom of speech nobody I don't
think believes it should be completely
unfilled in other words that anything
goes for example can you well Kanye West
for example when he literally is brought
back on Twitter and one of the first
things he does is post the Star of David
with a swastika inside it if you were
running Twitter even with your Zeal for
free speech which I share would you have
tolerated that
well I do think there's a place for
moderation I think that you get into
really tricky places when you try to
moderate people's opinions I think that
people have a right to opinions even
opinions that are wrong opinion that's a
deliberate attempt but you can I mean
that's not an opinion is it yeah it's
just that's basically inciting
Nazi hatred against the Jewish people
through symbolism isn't it yeah and
these platforms should be able to
moderate content that they believe is
obscene and objectively offensive that
isn't Viewpoint related I think they
absolutely should be able to they should
be able to moderate unlawful speech I
think that they give people a lot of
tools for example if you say things that
upset me all the time if you're trolling
me or making fun of me and making me
feel bad I can block you I can mute you
I have that control and I can control
who I see and who I hear from Leave it
in people's hands what they see what
they consume let them reach their own
decisions stop trying to decide for them
what's true what they're allowed to joke
about what they're allowed to believe
the thought control and speech control
that these private companies are
exercising right now is having
detrimental effects in society
just want to ask you one question
because you were at this dinner with
with Trump and in the background of the
picture of one of the other people you
were with the libs of tick tock I think
they call themselves they mock liberal
people for doing silly things uh in the
background yeah there was a picture of
what looked like Nick Clegg who's the
spokesman for Facebook
um who we know well over here was it
Nick leg was he there
I'm not sure I wasn't aware of that and
I don't know who else was present I've
got to say either it's Nick leg or it's
a dead ringer for Nick clay which
prompts all sorts of questions what the
hell was he doing there anyway
I've got to leave it there with you too
this was great thank you both very much
because you're both very tapped into all
this it is a complex thing I personally
am very glad Elon Musk is wrestling
through it because I think he comes from
a good place about it but we'll see he's
he's found out pretty quickly it's tough
it's tough in the jungle uh bakara and
so thank you both very much Dean and
Seth great to have you back on Twitter I
missed I've missed Babylon B you're
hilarious uh so good to see you buddy
thank you very much all right quick
reaction from from the pack um you're
staying with us for the show so don't
worry you've got plenty of air time but
it's about it's complex but would you
have let Trump back absolutely I think
that banning him for as long as he was
banned was completely disproportionate
you gave brilliant examples in your
intro about the Iranian Ayatollah you
know the bile that comes in the nonsense
that's churned out by the Kremlin it is
makes no sense whatsoever to ban Trump
in that context and you know your
interviewee made really important points
about no one has to follow Trump I mean
you can just unfollow you don't have to
read this stuff and I think the thing
that concerns me and and they're right
that these are private businesses they
it's up to them but they mustn't
masquerade as Arbiters of the truth they
must have masquerade as independent you
know perhaps they should say what their
position is we are a left-leaning
whatever
um so likely you're not going to get a
fair hearing if you disagree would you
have let Trump back on I would have
actually and yeah and for I know this is
going to be a shock to you Isabel but
actually there's a lot we agree on here
a fair woman and that's big and the
reason why I would have let him back on
actually is because I want to be able to
see him and I want to be able to hear
him right and I want to be able to
challenge him and my concern is is that
um if he doesn't have a platform where I
can do that at if he isn't accessible to
me if I can't hear him then he's going
to continue to say these things and I'm
going to be out well it's one of the
reasons actually Alex I for example
interviewed Alex Andrew Tate twice in my
last few months because I was made aware
by my sons all in my 20s that this guy
has an unbelievable following sort of
below the radar not on mainstream media
he'd be no platform everywhere and I
thought well this is actually really odd
situation and when I interviewed him
they both got gigantic viewer numbers I
mean off the charts it's a really good
example you've brought up there because
you know let's do an appraisal of what
social media has bought it is the most
pervasive and pernicious weapon of mass
destruction essentially against Society
that's been created in San Francisco
what does social media usher in it
bombards young people vulnerable people
with woke trends that see them mutilate
their own bodies it enables traffickers
to Usher tens of thousands of people as
human cargo across the channel it is
fundamentally changing the fabric of
society and it is penetrable are
manipulatable by foreign enemies
essentially the Genies out of the bottle
it's an unregulated Wild Wild West in
which life goes in parallel to regular
life and bad toxic things in the
internet seep down and tear society that
I have as a former newspaper editor we
were highly regulated in the newspaper
game we're highly regulated now in the
British television game by ofcom but
there's no regulation really that goes
on with these Tech Giants and in
particular we've had these stories of
these young girls who are getting sucked
down rabbit holes on Instagram taken to
places that fuel suicidal thoughts and
so on with no legal accountability or
regulation at the moment to stop these
companies letting their algorithms do
this kind of thing and that I think is
almost one of the biggest scandals of
all about it well we know about your own
situation don't we the terrifying
situation where you've had a death
threats and it's there for everybody to
see and everybody to read and yet the
police will come back and tell you well
I had I had it myself I mean somebody
made a death threat against me or my
son's Instagram in public clear specific
death threat I reported that the police
someone gets arrested five months later
and a year after that they come back and
say we can't do anything yeah so he gets
away with it I mean literally
unbelievable